we now have learned about statements
made by David de Pape the attacker of
Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's husband and
he is straight up admitting what this
was this was a politically motivated
attack in which he wanted to quote break
Nancy Pelosi's kneecaps so that she
would then have to be wheeled into
Congress in a wheelchair which would
really show Democrats that there are
consequences to their actions
that's it folks it's just right-wing
violence that's all it is it's no he was
a gay prostitute who was home with Paul
Pelosi and they were engaged in a
lover's quarrel there's no evidence for
any of it and we're going to get to that
in a moment
it's just terrorism that's all it is
there's a good Rolling Stone article by
Miles Clee conspiracy theories about
Pelosi attacker debunked by Pelosi
attacker David depape told police he
planned to take the house Speaker
hostage and break her kneecaps if she
lied to him
that is the bottom line here this was a
sworn affidavit FBI special agent
Stephanie Miner who's a domestic
terrorism specialist described 42 year
old Berkeley Man David depape told
police he planned to take speaker Pelosi
hostage interrogate her and possibly
break her kneecaps she wasn't home at
the time of the invasion
the Pape broke through a rear glass door
of the residence with a hammer he later
used that hammer to beat Paul Pelosi he
brought zip ties tape rope and gloves
he was going to talk to her if she told
the truth he would release her if she
lied he would break her knee pack
kneecaps a debate described Pelosi as
quote leader of the pack of Lies told by
the Democratic Party
there uh is nothing nothing to the
right-wing conspiracy theories which we
will delve into a little bit more but
think about it he is openly telling us
why he did it
it's terrorism it's a form of domestic
terrorism it's violence against our
democratically elected uh uh uh
officials that's what it is and the Pape
said to it authorities he didn't flee
when Paul Pelosi was able to call 9-1-1
because quote much like the American
founding fathers with the British he was
fighting against tyranny
without the option of surrender
Republicans are like well he was a gay
prostitute the paper's like I'm not gay
or a prostitute I'm just a right winger
like you guys
so maybe it was antifa some kind of
double agent a secret BLM member or
whatever but of course none of that
would be true and meanwhile Fox News
continues to give the conspiracy
theories the benefit of the doubt as the
conspiracy theories are increasingly
debunked Fox News has to play more and
more koi and just say it's not really
all adding up here's one such clip there
are a number of unanswered questions
regarding the case like who opened the
door for police and why did Paul Pelosi
allegedly describe de Pape at one point
in a conversation with authorities as a
friend and if he wasn't let in how did
he get up there and break in given the
amount of security in the area
of course we have most of those answers
already and we will talk in more detail
about some of those claims in a moment
but for now I want to talk about one of
the other claims that's regularly being
made about this attack
when you're looking for a good
documentary to watch you scroll through
Netflix and Hulu for a while there
aren't that many you realize you've seen
the good ones what if I told you there's
a streaming platform exclusively for
documentaries with the best selection
where you won't run out of top quality
documentaries that is curiosity stream
with a massive catalog of the newest and
best documentaries classic titles from
years ago exclusive content you can't
find anywhere else I just watched
Pompeii disaster Street I visited
Pompeii in Italy before I wish I had
seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiositystream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below